Donald Trump's former vice president
Mike Pence has joined the race for the
2024 Republican nomination and launched
a strong attack on the former president
campaigning in Iowa yesterday Pence
blasted Trump over the assault on the
capitol saying his former boss put
himself above the Constitution Robert
Casa is in Des Moines Bob good morning
good morning Vlad yesterday was perhaps
the most forceful we've ever seen pence
in terms of taking on his former running
mate Donald Trump criticizing his
handling of January 6 and some of
Trump's policies after the event when I
asked Pence why are you doing this right
now Penn simply told me it's time
we are here because we know that Iowa
was the right place to start our engines
for the Great American comeback
warmer vice president Mike Pence made
his presidential run official on
Wednesday and wasted no time going after
his former boss and the current
Republican front-runner Donald Trump
president Trump's words were Reckless
they endangered my family pens took aim
at Trump for pressuring him to overturn
the 2020 election I hope Mike is going
to do the right thing I hope so anyone
who asks someone else to put them over
the Constitution should never be
president of the United States again
and he doubled down at a town hall in
Iowa Wednesday night president Trump was
wrong then he's wrong now with roughly a
dozen candidates in the race and Pence
polling in the single digits he's
counting on a strong showing in next
year's Iowa caucuses well there's a lot
of candidates in the race right now so I
think it'll be an uphill climb for for
everybody Pence hopes his conservative
record will appeal to the state's
religious voters I'm a Christian a
conservative and a republican in that
order when something isn't working you
stop and you try something new meanwhile
in his home state of North Dakota
governor Doug bergam made his case for
why he's running for the White House we
need a leader who's clearly focused on
three things economy energy and National
Security
all last night Pence was asked about
whether Trump should be indicted for his
handling of classified records Pence
said no one is above the rule of law but
he also said he hopes the justice
department does not move forward with
what he characterizes something that
would be a dramatic and divisive
indictment Gail
all right Bob got it thank you very much